hi there so this do you know what i'm
not gonna mince about it i am really
excited about this one because i'm
joined by brian may adam lambert and
roger taylor from queen
um how does it feel for you all to be
here today it is there's such a buzz
here isn't there yeah there definitely
is yes it looked amazing uh even when we
were doing the check they could see all
the way down the mall as an awful lot of
people yeah
we're excited yeah the crowds are
incredible out there amazing yeah it's a
real feel a feeling of jubilation very
genuine people i think yeah we're all
happy we're still here we're happy the
queen's still here we're personally
happy that we're still here to do this
thing
which is incredible what an honor
amazing and and i gotta say i'm so lucky
to be up here as a guest of the united
kingdom and a guest of
queen and as a queen on this stage i
mean we were looking out there at where
the the royals are gonna be sitting and
i thought am i in a jousting match
what's going on this is amazing i'm so
excited it's an amazing amphitheater out
there isn't it it's kind of like there's
four stages and then all of the seating
around it and it has to be said probably
one of the most famous performances was
for the golden jubilee you guys up on
the roof
where on earth do you go from the roof
well you will see
somewhere different
yeah we've been working on it for months
it's very hard not to talk about it
actually it's hard to keep that secret
but yeah we have an interesting
new place to go let's put it that way
which i think will be suitably epic for
this epic occasion yes but basically we
want to just bring
a lot of joy because there's been a lot
of misery in the last two years and this
is a wonderful occasion you know to to
do this for this incredible woman that's
been there all of our lives
it is really true two years we've had
the pandemic obviously some are still
wearing masks and things it's been a
rough time and you get that sense that
people want to come out and celebrate so
that's important yeah yeah we've been
wearing masks on the tour i mean we it's
very precious to us to play all the
dates that we've booked for so this is
unusual for us not to be wearing the
mask we do the sanitizing everything
because we have to we don't want to
disappoint anybody and yeah there's a
big risk out there still
i have to ask you have you ever spoken
to the queen about that moment that
you're up on her roof i have actually
yes
what did she say she said oh it was you
it was nice it was it was a yeah i've
spoken to her a couple of times but that
particular occasion i was with eric
clapton and jimmy page and jeff beck
and um i kind of introduced them to her
and um and i said i was so i'm sorry i
was the guy making all that noise on
your roof and says oh it was you was it
yes mom
so you're worried you're going to upset
her again well i don't think she'd be
too upset i think she's very she's a
very good sport
and i think she's making a contribution
to her own event which would be
memorable forever
i'm just being told in my ear by my
producer and we're showing it on air at
the moment that the crowds out there
apparently aren't doing the clapping for
radio garga
they're ready so they're ready
they're getting warm god damn it we're
not doing that one
they're not doing it anyways
and just one final question what does
her majesty mean to you all
she's the kind of the wallpaper of our
lives you know in the nicest way she's
just always been there and like a rock
through all the miserable
times and all the good times so yeah
yeah
she's extraordinary i think whether you
approve of royalty or not not the whole
principle you cannot help but admire
this woman who's done her job so
incredibly well for so long with such
dignity
and applause yeah you you got it you've
got to admire
you adam you're not from this country
but she's she it's
admired around the world absolutely and
and from you know from where i grew up
knowing who the queen was and and
learning about her more recently
what an impressive woman you know to to
you know helm this country for as long
as she has with such grace
and class um i think it's going to be
quite a night
thanks sorry for nicking the name
well yeah exactly you have to share it
thank you i've got to let you guys go
but that was amazing can't wait for
later so yeah big surprise for later
um yeah that's queen